that you have a deal with your stuntman  yeah well so so we do fights for all  these movies and um and and they're  really good Fighters and I mean not so  much so I like to box you know for fun  and I've been doing it for a few decades  but but I'm but I usually end up  accidentally punching them  um and so my deal with them is it  started on the first movie I told the  first guy that I fought with in The  Bourne Identity for every time I  accidentally punch you in the face I'll  buy you a bottle of champagne and the  guy was a professional kickboxer so he  and from France and he was like this is  a very good deal for me  and so at the end I owed him a case of  champagne and that's and so 12 bottles  of champagne so and that's basically my  average on the four movies and then on  this one I fight Vincent Cassell you  know a great french actor but he had no  interest in my champagne he was like  Matt just do not hit me in the face